I think it's fair to say you are the
Golden Goose of the UFC right now man I
don't know I don't know about that I do
but I mean there's Connor who's their
green Golden Goose yeah but as far as
like I I think you've become kind of
this undeniable fighter where your next
fight we're talking big boy fights and
Dana and the UFC seem to be on board you
and Connor there's a lot of smoke with
that Dana was like it makes a lot of
sense Chandler Connor makes a lot of
sense a sport of mixed martial arts and
especially the lightweight division is
better when Conor McGregor is part of it
but he needs to come back at the right
time agree not Russia and not Russia